salut à tous un mec de 2 m
07 on va dire ça dépend des mesures de m
07 qui s'avère être aussi un des joueurs
les plus adroits de sa cuvée on va
parler dans ce podcast de patrick
baldwin junior joueurs de milwaukee en
est fier son portrait de futurs drafté
en 30 minutes chrono
et je vous rappelle que notre site c'est
envergure point c'est au abonnez-vous
aux podcasts pour recevoir la
notification or on est présent sur quasi
toutes les plates formes d'écouté
abonnez-vous à youtube planète draft où
les mois notamment direct mais aussi
pour recevoir les podcasts et puis
abonnez-vous à switch des stream
hebdomadaire de grande qualité on
regarde du film en direct analyse des
vidéos en direct de joueur ancien ou de
rocchi n'diaye ou autres de prospects
quoi donc on brosse le portrait de
patrick baldwin junior avec alan manu et
hugues salue les gas salut à
un mot pour décrire patrick baldwin un
mot vous aideront à un mot sur côté
grand abandonné
merci c'est fini pour ce podcast
non on va vous donner les détails quand
même patrick baldwin junior numéro 10 de
notre dernier big bore de notre
classement des meilleurs joueurs de la
draft nba 2022 qui est il ce monsieur
que manu tu a qualifié de grand eh bien
je vais te demander de nous décrire un
peu son parcours s'il te plaît c'est
l'intérieur de l'université de milwaukee
pour le wisconsin mais à green bay le 18
novembre il a son père patrick baldwin
seniors et le coach de cette université
depuis 2010 est donc c'est un peu ce cas
l'idée le choix du fiston c'est son père
ajoie en initier et sa maman au volet à
north western 2 donc lui des jeunes de
sportifs et pour lui aussi comme kendall
bornes il fait son son cursus au lycée
chez lui hamilton sussex il n'a pas fait
de pré beaucoup l'ont reconnu comme
comme certains d'autres prospère
américain et salue comme valu
l'étiquette de 2,5 et prospects cinq
étoiles de unanimement de la part des
différents sites de spécialistes us les
joueurs de l'année 2020 de son état avec
une moyenne 24 points et presque 11
rebonds ce qui lui permet d'être
sélectionné au all american home and all
american et au nike hoop summit et donc
deux événements qu'il a pas plus jouer à
cause de la situation aux états unis
il a fait partie de team usa l été
dernier avec au championnat du monde u19
qui a remporté le le titre contre la
france notamment en finale il a joué
tous les matches c'est points de moyenne
5 rebonds et 2 passes
et le chose à de ce par quoi retenir
c'est qu'il a été gêné sur une blessure
sur sa dernière année en school c'est
une déchirure aux ligaments de la
cheville gauche
qui se blessent en décembre 2020 et ce
qui lui a fait manquer la fin de la
saison highschool du coup et c'est une
cheville qui lui ou sur laquelle est
également été gêné cette saison
il a manqué plusieurs matches à cause de
cette cheville il a tellement
manqué plusieurs matches à cause du coc
vide et finalement cette année il a très
peu joué il a joué que 14 matches sur
les 24 25 de son équipe ouais et ont
redit une nouvelle fois mais c'est
vraiment une toute petite fac un milieu
qui c'est c'est une toute petite
conférence petit faxer division 1 mais
le quasiment le plus bas niveau congrès
et il était courtisé sûr que mon sa
liste finale seydoux georgetown kentucky
michigan north carolina du ciel elle en
dit nyan win ce qu'annecy
petit quizz comme ça je en
rebondissements est ce que vous savez le
seul joueur all star sur les 25
dernières années qui sort de cette
conférence all stars non
là du doigt une accolade
non je vais essayer de trouver cette
année aux il ya quoi comme fac la barre
vatine fac qui n'est plus dans cette
danseuse conférence ah oui
tu là je vais pas trop
mais quand ça a été vu ses coordonnées
vois tu joues un peu peur était un
orateur à l'époque était
exactement ils ont changé deux fois de
conférence avant d'arriver à une fois la
piste et ensuite la milice na waie sais
pas voilà tu t'en fais c'est beau très
beau trivia mais à l'époque je regardais
même pas si beau gordon hayward c'est le
début des visionnages n 6
hugues par le nom du physique de patrick
baldwin alors je sais pas quelle taille
tu as moins ça dépend des sites comme
d'habitude ça aussi entre 2 6 et 2 09
ouais moi je l'avais de 0,8 donc on va
partir à peu près là dessus c'est un
ailier qui joue du coup au poste de
pivot quasiment à milwaukee parce que
c'est comme si une petite fac il ya très
peu de joueurs grands finalement donc
ils se retrouvent un peu me l'a pas par
défaut
99 kg et l'a pris quasiment plus de 15
kilos sur les deux dernières années donc
une grosse prise de masse une envergure
mesurer à 211 cm donc ça fait 6 pieds 11
si on essaie d'être dans le système
métrique de notre ben adoré
si je dois parler du joueur dans son
corps déjà inac et qui a passe pas si
con ça dramatique pour lui j'aime dans
la vie de sa carrière sinon c'est pas
très flashy pour être un peu plus
sérieux c'est un joueur qui n'est pas
très athlétique si on prend la moyenne m
biais dans toutes les dimensions un
premier pas très lent
latéralement très compliqué notamment
dans la rotation des hanches dans l'
équilibre avec le bassin c'est plus une
menace verticale de très haute qualité
même si c'est un joueur qui compense on
en parlait par des parrains qi basket
très très très développé c'est pas un
joueur qui prend le dessus physiquement
sur ses chances et défenseur direct
malgré qu'ils soient plus large que les
jours qu'ils affrontent les ailiers de
l' horizon en fait il lui faut il rendre
quasiment 7 cm à chaque fois mais
n'arrivent pas à prendre le dessus et on
l'a vu lorsqu'il a joué contre des
équipements potable et je pense à
florida colorado il a affronté deadwood
jd job et walker et qu'ils y ont mis la
misère
athlétiquement parle
très bien donc un joueur papa très pas
très physiquement sexy sans parler de la
séquence en partie de sa peau évidemment
alan
pourquoi on en parle alors de patrick
baldwin junior pourquoi est il des
tétines en recrue 5 l'étoile pourquoi
est il aujourd'hui prévue au 1er tour
chez je crois à l'intégralité des plus
grands sites de big board note draft
pour ses qualités de tir sa qualité de
choc mais coeur à sa taille le rapport
taille
capacité de tir reste pour moi très
intéressant et assez impressionnant à
dire un joueur qui est entre deux
convois de 0,5 et 0,8 qui est capable
d'avoir un tir aussi et c'est
intéressant parce que ça se reflète pas
énormément dans les statistiques on peut
voir mais la gestuelle la facilité avec
laquelle ils peuvent prendre des tickets
shoots prendre des tirs en mouvement
mettre un petit peu de sueur du pool up
aussi
ça ça reste assez rare et parle quand
même d'un profil de joueurs qui je pense
a tous pour une vieille être flore
spacing found c'est-à-dire un 3/4
utilisé surtout ball à qui on peut faire
prendre tiré sur pick'n pop tirer dans
les coins attaqué je pense à closer
parce que comme l'a dit lui que c'est
pas un athlète incroyable mais avec un
meilleur spéciaux midi pourra je pense
attaquer les clauses out donc on achète
un choc mais coeur un joueur qui dans
une rotation une bio aura cette
labellisation de tireurs très bien donc
patrick baldwin junior j'ai une question
tout de suite pour manu
toi tu as parlé de ses blessures au
lycée hughes a parlé de sa prise de
masse c'est difficile de pas faire la
corrélation entre les deux est ce que tu
as l'impression sur les matchs des
derniers que tu as pu voir qu'ils
bougent moins bien ou qu'il a toujours
finalement bouger comme ça c'est à dire
un peu eu du mal sur l'explosivité je
n'ai pas vu au lycée j'ai juste vu du
coup j'avais fait des matches du 19 et
j'ai essayé de faire cette année au mcs
très très compliqué visuellement
et non j'ai pas de moi je fends à
l'écran en tout cas j'ai pas vu
différence notable enfin s'il ya rien
qui m'a choqué parce qu'il joue avec une
troupe assez fluide notamment sur le
chemin les kings qui joue avec une jeune
ou une genouillère
sur certains matches et moi cette cette
prise de poids me fais peut-être me dire
que
la fin surtout je trouve qu'il est à la
rue physiquement quoi luxe parce que tu
en penses moi les matchs que j'ai
regardé le gars il était en nage quoi au
bout de cinq minutes c'est ça et son
papa qui est le coach ne le fait pas
beaucoup joué 2 donc séquence d'affilée
c'est un des premiers mec qui sort alors
que c'est le seul jour potable de son
équipe info être honnête il n'est pas
capable d'enchaîner jour des choix des
grosses séquences et pour le problème de
pied ça remonte même à dès sa première
année de lycée en tête il a jamais je
crois fait une saison complète depuis
tiverny school donc ça c'est inquiétant
peut-être encore plus que le manque
d'explosivité parce que
parce que ça en devient handicapant
alors après moi je pense qu'avec une
bonne prépa physique il ferait quand
même plus de choses que ce qu'il fait là
j'allais dire j'allais dire physiquement
hughes
ou est-ce que tu que tu projettes en
année 1 1 qui est ce que tu le mets sur
le terrain pour quoi faire ainsi si tu
le draft
ouais je le mets de la première année
sur le terrain parce que il peut créer
un nouveau respect sinon j'étais quelque
chose qui fera rapidement je pense qu'il
va avoir un rôle très limité et tout ça
casse avec les mêmes en fait il va poser
des écrans en pick and pop et il va
tirer à trois points je me demande même
si certaines équipes ont pas vouloir
l'utiliser en poste cinq internes
parce que finalement c'est un joueur
intelligent et pour avoir un spéciaux
optimale mettre des écrans nivea trois
points et c'est un très bon passeur
quelque chose qu'on voit pas beaucoup
côté de milwaukee parce qu'encore une
fois c'est des glands à côté de lui
donc voilà je pense que ça va être son
rôle et que on va très vite atteindre
son son plafond mais avec une valeur
positive sur le terrain offensivement
parlant d' alan skis et ski la question
qui fâche sans doute pas mal
d'observateurs et ce qui peut défendre
j'ai encore vu une vidéo où il joua
comptes bancaires au l'année dernière
manque héros de duke qui avait projeté
top 3
ils disent feliz fait pourrir à chaque
départ en dribbles on n'a pas
l'impression qui peut défendre sur des
postes 4 explosif qua
non c'est assez c'est assez c'est assez
complexe et pas fait pour défendre en
nba il faut avoir soi la volonté de
mindset ça il a pas vraiment et parce
que ça a toujours été un petit peu une
star patrick ballerines ça fait
longtemps qu'on entend parler ça ou
alors faudra des qualités athlétiques
qui font que moi tu peux te permettre
peut-être d'être moins à fond dans ta
tête mais ton corps des habitudes vont
permettre de te rattraper il a aucun des
deux et même quand j'ai fait comme manu
j'étais hier soir j'étais à avoir trois
matches de son fils a eu 19 donc qu'on
disait qui comme assez potables pour
voir une fois que c'était j'ai fait j'ai
refait la finale contre la france
malheureusement je m'en suis toujours
pas remis
phil australie et
la canada en demi-finale et non même
compte des petits qui se fait il saute
sur les feintes him or il arrive pas
détenir au rebond il est parfois un peu
soft là où il est bon c'est sûr la
lecture loin du ballon du deuxième
rideau c'est un joueur très cérébral
choc entre une ballerine c'est un genre
qui sur le terrain doit savoir où se
placer replace d'ailleurs souvent ses
coéquipiers que ce soit mérité mieux et
c est avec
vous continuez l'eau qui cette année
donc je pense qu'il pourrait il pourra
peut-être attendre le stade de
défenseurs non négatif parce qu'il
pourra faire les bonnes rotations il
fera pas d'erreurs mais par contre quand
il sera mis six parents tenaient un
switch sur lui et qu'on met sur un petit
ou qu'il ait posté par un ailier
puissant ça va être problématique très
bien on vend du rêve vous voyez c'est ça
non mais et c'est intéressant parce que
finalement moi je l'aimé je crois que je
n'ai pas vu en or or loterie
même je parlais tout à l'heure premier
tour mais je crois pas que je les ai vus
or loterie ou alors dans des dans des
big board un peu un peu fantaisiste quoi
en tout cas qui se veulent originaux
et un stock de boxe
vous certains d'entre vous l'ont or
loterie peut-être non il va encore
descendre jusqu'où peut-il descendre
entre 20 et 30 parce qu'il fait trop
bien et que le profil erreurs
et blanc tu parles bien jusqu'où il peut
aller sur un big board ou sur mac
jusqu'où ils jusqu'où toi tu peux le
descendre sur un big board et en
conséquence
sur cinq est lequel par rapport aux
autres profils de cette cuvée
jusqu'où enfin comment évaluer son
potentiel inférieur donc hamon a tant de
joueurs au dessus lui c'est à dire 5 10
15 20 sur un big board les mains entre
20 et 30 parce que je pense qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose à faire
avec lui et si c'est ce que je disais
sur notre facture ou whatsapp qui se
trouvent dans il terminé 26e pic à miami
et dans trois ans il est trop fort et
all-star quoi typique où je pense que
quand je le vois c'est typiquement le
voir que j'imagine devenir tomber dans
la situation parfaite pour lui exploser
c'est pour ça que
j'y crois pas personnellement c'est pas
un genre qui me fin mais en même temps
je pense qu'il n'a pas fait le bon choix
en allant voir dans cette université là
où ils se retrouvent comme 10 à la met
plus d'émules les perfs régler tout seul
quoi c'est horrible c'est vraiment
horrible pour lui et
pour
pour évaluer ce genre de choses c'est
que c'est très très compliqué quoi
moi je me pose pas plus sur le fiba
vasily en réalité moi je trouve ça en
fait je trouve pas ça négatif parce que
pour moi il ya rien à tirer de sa saison
à milwaukee si ce n'est c'est pas une
option une mais on le savait en fait on
le savait que patrick baldwin ça serait
pas un porteur de balle numéro un un
joueur comme ça parce que même en vivant
on avait des indices si dans le contexte
si bas on le redit
inefficace si les stars de l'équipe
c'est chez tom green jedi vie
ou même une trentaine davis mike miles y
joue à tizi ouzou et l'ubs à l'unil a le
rôle de
poste 4 qui sort du banc est là pour
mettre des tirs pour écarter le terrain
il le fait bien d'ailleurs dans les nues
dans la finale contre la france en demi
finale comme de cadres donc en fait moi
je vais pas trop le descendre par
rapport à sa saison à russe continue les
eaux qui parce que j'avais chaves h avec
ça allait être cataclysmique
en fait j'attends des qu'être surpris je
le voyais être très solide en initiateur
d'attac là je leur ai vraiment monter
mais pour moi il a quand même ce
plancher comme la digue du tir il ya ce
plancher de la passe parce que je le dis
quand il ya des flashes ont fleuri da
contre colorado où il fait des bonnes
des bonnes rotations il arrive à voir il
faut que c'est un bon pas c'est en fait
ce truc c'est un bon passeur chaud que
c'est un bon tireur tu peux pas trop le
descendent à sa taille moi je les 14-15
je crois je peux pas trop le descendre
parce que
pour moi ce jour là je vais avoir
plusieurs contres en nba je le vois être
dans une rotation et comme l'a dit manu
surtout s'il tombe dans un dans un
système qui peut masquer ses faiblesses
ses marques de latéralité qu'on le fait
surtout a beaucoup tiré à prendre des
décisions balle en main et qu'on lui le
fait prendre beaucoup de tirs peu
compliqué cette année j'ai un peu
regardé il est à hilla à 28% à 3 points
mais parce que il y prend quasiment un
tiers ses tirs soit sur la fin d'une
horloge soit sur du pool of contestées
c'est une équipe arrive à masquer ses
faiblesses arrive à pouvoir vraiment le
limiter à un rôle plus plus mais en
réalité c'est pas c'est pas si simple à
faire c'est pas genre ont beaucoup
parlent de miami avec max russe ou de
cadres mizan oui mais en fait max que
certains cas dans le tarn sont aussi de
très bons joueurs à la base pour ce qui
a peut-être si on était sous drafté vous
même pas drafté donc je pense qu'il faut
un bon contexte pour lui mais je pense
qu'il a que 19 ans est un bon tireur
c'est un joueur intelligent et il a
montré dans le contexte autres donc avec
ce team usa où il était un rouage un
rôle moins important qu'ils étaient très
variables qui pouvaient terminer les
matches donc j'ai pas trop le baiser
nemanja bjelica
ci devient plus dur
dans le stream avec nicolas lang du coup
on a fait un stream qui est le joueur du
csp limoges et qui en attendant sale
français spécialiste du tir il disait
que problème c'est que ce joueur il a
pas cette variation dans son tir il a
passé deux tirs différents ou est
regardée du clip il voyait plus un jour
quitter du catch and shoot mais trouvez
que l'équilibré au niveau du bassin
était très mauvais quand il devait
tourner mais qu'ils leurs proches des
bons shooteurs en sortant des écrans ce
que les mecs de maïa michaud et ex
excellemment bien et je ne conprend avis
bertal
en disant est ce qu'il pourrait avoir ce
rôle là il me dit mais davies par tonne
qui chuteraient tellement mieux au
niveau n 6 et même avec des moins bons
gars est tellement plus physique donc ça
peut être une projection quasi optimales
en fait j'ai l'impression même s'il ya
des croquis de la passe comme je le
disais
je pense que c'est ce qu' il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas eu une créativité à
avoir au niveau du contexte où il va
tomber sur lui donner des ballons face à
des défenseurs qui seront certainement
souvent plus petits
au niveau du de l'album qu'il adore ça
sa mort est ce qu ils faisaient beaucoup
shooté au dessus du but que moi j'étais
au dessus du comme il était plus grand
que les les adversaires il n'est même
couleur shooter 2 sec avenir incertain
touché à mi distance était plutôt bien
je pense que ça on peut clairement voir
son meilleur match il le fait dans une
zone contre je crois que c'est oral
roberts ou robert moris un des deux
ponts des remarques sur deux zones 2 3
mais il se met au milieu il les enchaîne
donc mais en mai il est très à l'aise là
dessus et même je vote oui ça peut être
y être plus en plus de zones ça peut
être aussi une sorte de d'armes pour
deux autres braqueurs fort pour la nba
parce que avec moins de talent bien sûr
mais ce qu'a pu être par moments au tout
début michael porter
genre de joueurs surtout - d'explosivité
quoi beaucoup moins d'explosivité mais
beaucoup de roach métier et par un
athlète plus je compare pas les jours
jusque ce que denver a laissé à faire
avec porter au début avant qu'ils soient
vraiment à 100% physiquement et où c'est
peut-être ce qu'on peut faire au début
avec baldwin aux tipa explose ça va fans
de dead
man u est ce que
est ce que tu peux me parler de 2,7
cette intelligence de jeu dont on
crédite patrick baldwin depuis tout à
l'heure comment elles se matérialisent
sur le terrain est sous toit la passe
moi j'aime beaucoup son instinct
prévision passe je trouve ça super
intéressant pour un gars comme ça mais
heureusement ce ne doit pas trop sur les
stades parce que ils sont quand même des
joueurs qui savent pas faire des lieux
ouverts donc c'est compliqué
mais c'est vraiment ça et je te vois
vraiment comme un
grand jeu quand je parle de ça c'est
vraiment il est ancré dans souvent c'est
sur le 45 degrés il va tout réussir à
trouver quelqu'un si c'est vraiment dans
cette optique là mais je pense qu'à
terme il peut vraiment avoir un rôle
d'initiateur c'est parce que je devrai
faire mais capable comme ça de diriger
trouver la bonne extra pas c'est pour
pour le shoot pour la faute c'est comme
ça que je le vois mois alternant le
joueur intelligent
le joueur intelligent vous à l'année ce
que tu as
psychologiquement dans la dans la tête
est ce que tu as l'impression d'un
joueur qui joue moi j'ai presque
l'impression qu'il était prêtre aux
jeunes
i comme tu as dit l'été star très jeune
il il est très mature fois tu regarde
des vidéos d'il ya trois ans donc il
avait 16 ans il parlait quand un type de
30 ans corinne schmitz qui
l'interviewait
est ce que est ce qu il a la grinta pour
pour aller faire des extras des extras
travaux de développement pour perdre ce
petit gras qu'il a maintenant excès
oui il peut peut-être être labellisé un
peu sorte je pense
après en terme de comportement moi j'ai
ça à milwaukee bon le comportement d'un
plat star de l'équipe il est coaché par
papa donc difficile timur essais j'ai
trouvé très bien sortait du banc alors
que il aurait pu peut-être se dire un
tank et 9 tonnes ok c'est un mec des
mythes médor ou d'autres moi je suis un
prospect 5 étoiles tout ça s'est plutôt
bien passé ils sortent ces mêmes traits
un peu s'il sortait du banc sur le côté
il a plu il était vraiment très très
influent il était très très positif très
dans l'énergie
après que ça se fait très belle
programmation de stars et de sportifs
très jeune quoi par le père par
gros joueur dans l'état du wisconsin qui
a un joueur qui sort de plus en plus
qu'un état qui sort de plus en plus de
joueurs qui est de plus en plus
compétitif
ouais il fait un peu programme est
peut-être peut-être trop parfait trop
modeler mais quand on l'a vu dans un
contexte comme le contexte fiba ça s'est
bien passé donc je pense que deux sont à
prendre en compte human eu vous avez des
choses a ajouté là dessus
si tu as the matrix moment où il met
enfin dedans parce qu'il sortait de deux
grosses galères sur les tous premiers
matches il explose de rage tu vas y
célèbre vraiment ils commençaient à
douter l'adversaire donc il ya ce côté
ce côté très orgueilleux attend parfois
ça il la manu oui mais juste revenir sur
la wii sur l'âme j'ai pas si on peut
plus aller l'intelligence ou non pas mon
blague la culture pour f g en faisant
les recherches de présentation j'ai vu
tous les ans à la halle à encens
de merde comme on appelle ça
de pour pâques il avait des chocolats
non à 90 ans de la fin d'année scolaire
tout simplement il est
vrai je perds mes mots ça fait longtemps
que je vais plus à l'école
en fait chaque sortie de l'année ça
marche à chaque achat canettes de
scolaires il était toujours parmi les
meilleurs il était toujours félicité
parler des jurys des choses comme ça au
niveau au niveau de son état mais je
pense que c'est ça oui ça montre aussi
un peu le le caractère du bonhomme et
qu'il ya sûrement un travail de faire là
dessus autour comme ça ne se fait pas
sans rappeler celle de l'intelligence ou
mentale ou je sais pas trop comment
appeler ça psychologique je sais pas
trop mais je trouve qu'il ya un travail
à faire là dessus
oui c'est une tronche à
une tronche as ça ça se voit ça s'entend
même sur le terrain ça se voit parfois
ils surent réfléchi quoi il va anticiper
de rotation à l'avance alors qu'en fait
il ya oublié qu'ils jouaient contre fort
toi une pure audio quoi donc
donc effectivement c'est
je vais de john consorts et c'est vrai
j'avais oublié ah oui c'est vrai et qui
réussit très bien c'est la soirée dans
l'avion c'est la soirée trivial est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à ajouter
sur notre autre ami patrick bard lwin
d'union vous souhaite d'arriver vite
dans une conception de jouer avec des
joueurs nba quel contexte vas-y quel
contexte demo
idéal une équipe venue pour moi je
trouve les rigoles souvent sur les
sacramento les knicks tout ça en réalité
pour un joueur qui sort d'une là
l'horizon league coaché par son père cas
j'ai vraiment été mis en difficulté je
pense que n'importe quelle équipe nba
avec un spacing avec des joueurs plus
anciens puits qui va respecter parce
qu'il connaît je pense que ça va
vraiment bien pouvoir le faire débuter
sa carte professionnelle déjà de voir
tes la summer league par exemple des la
summer league comment il est utilisé
comment ça va se passer quand il va
jouer avec des bons joueurs initiés ou
des routiers sophomore sa lettre m et
j'ai très hâte de voir dans un autre
contexte je sais pas s'ils ont des pics
de draft tiens je peux vérifier en même
temps je viens d'avoir changé en avoir
une vision
à minnesota
sortie de banc il apprend avec nasri qui
était un peu que dans la même situation
que lui
ils ont 16 minnesota faisable mcdaniels
vraiment hors
jeu et héros n'ont pas pas prête je vous
plais
bon pour vous
mais on adore on adore on adore
potentiel
c'est la question bonus messieurs c'est
la question bonus toujours en lien plus
ou moins
évident avec le joueur après les
fromages suisses lors du dernier podcast
on va parler un peu basket quand même
parce que j'ai pas trouvé de spécialités
du luis consignes en vérité le fromage
aussi
l'ennemi
donc patrick baldwin est né dans le
wisconsin et jouissent consignes
milwaukee et à des champions en titre
milwaukee bucks qui a dans ses rangs
deux des chouchous à l'époque du podcast
et chouchou personnel aussi j'ai nommé
pas de caunes automne et dompter di
vincenzo donc la question bonus et est
ce que vous préférez c'est vraiment
uniquement stylistique est ce que vous
préférez le notre-dame de pâtes
connaughton ou le vila nova de dompter
di vincenzo je n'ai pas dit qu'ils
étaient la meilleure équipe c'est assez
évident que c'était villanova qu'à
remporter le titre mais je vous demande
votre équipe préférée le moteur d'un m2
patronne automne hipsters calypso non ça
pour faire plaisir au chef
asturiana qobuz thierry hanh grandes
émettrices jackson
que des mecs mesures d'âgés seront pas
forcément là exprès il avait rien
non parce que c'est l'équipe qui a
failli battre le n'zi que le sien lui
avant qu'il parte comprise conséquent
ils auraient dû les battre et voilà
notre dame c'est l'équipier connu pour
achille twenty one et ses tours de
l'effort était voiture
c'est un programme qui joue les yeux du
pays et leur équipe de foot est bien
supérieure à celle de zidane au bond
pour ça
et le coach je trouve qu'il ressemble à
l'acteur de shining l'âge oublié le nom
mais que fan des lakers phil jackson
voilà jack nicholson le coach et
nicholson c'est vrai je n'ai jamais
pensé à un mike bray en doppelganger de
jack nicholson bien vu que toi tu
préfères nova ouais il à nova et
j'adorais de vincenzo en plus donc
double bonus villanova en rappel c'est
une équipe incroyable jen brunson phil
boot il en europe 9 il boude j'ai
rien à dire qu'au nord non il n'était
pas été pas dans ça ne leur dites est
parti mystérieusement
eric pascal michael bridge ils ont
marqué son mari spelman c'est quand même
damir romss by country
et coline gillespie et german samuel ce
qui sont encore là cinq ans après et qui
vont peut-être être acquise soit dans
dix ans
on a des bonus
kovi kovi kovi de plus
man u man u man u est ce que tu peux
venir elle est exceptionnelle
exception bon ben pour une fois j'ai le
droit de voter je vote notre dame donc
ça fait 2-2
et ça sera un sondage à départager je
vote notamment pour bozic olsson qui est
vide j beeching vijay bitume la crau
incroyable superbe équipe et j'arrive et
blake lively qui joue donc aujourd'hui à
notre dame ont enfreint un podcast
prochainement sur blaye crise mais on a
besoin encore de le voir jouer je crois
parce qu'il progresse de match en match
il n'était pas attendu à ce niveau là
donc eh bien on a fait patrick belwind
juniors on vous demande de partager
l'épisode cieux si ça vous plaît au
moins de vous abonner à notre chaîne en
parler autour de vous si vous connaissez
des gens qui kiffent le côté draft ou
qu'ils supportent une franchise nba qui
ne décolle pas puisque la brasse et le
meilleur moyen de faire décoller votre
franchise
rappelez vous en
on vous fait des bisous abonnez vous à
nos contenus et surtout prenez soin de
vous ciao ciao